I'm going to pass it to one of my co anchors there and we have any news, Jason. Today there's a single alert on the 405. You're going to want to go ahead and take surface streets. Try some pulpit or the canyons back out to sports
我要把它交给我的联合主播之一，Jason，你有什么新闻吗？今天405号公路有一个单点警报。你最好还是走地面道路。试试Pulpit或者峡谷路，绕开体育新闻。
with Sean. Hey, your sports Sean. Does anybody want to guess my middle name? What are you doing, dude? You're supposed to be the sports guy. Sorry. You know, when someone throws you the ball, you don't drop it. Well, I could talk
和Sean一起。嘿，体育界的Sean。有人想猜猜我的中间名吗？你这是在干什么，伙计？你应该是体育解说员。抱歉。你知道，当别人把球传给你时，你不能把它掉在地上。好吧，我可以谈谈
about traffic. I don't know about sports. Well, that's the joke, dingy. Dallas, Dallas Cowboys and the Bears are playing this Saturday. Okay, I'm going to pass it to you. Well, we're just talking about how Sean is the problem. We
交通。我对体育一窍不通。好吧，这就是个笑话，笨蛋。达拉斯，达拉斯牛仔队和熊队这个周六有比赛。好吧，我要把它交给你了。我们刚才还在讨论Sean才是那个问题所在。我们
never have this issue when your guest or my guest. It's just we always start right on the line. You know, it's not just me. It's not me. It's not me. I'm always on time. No, but it's your vibe. Yeah, vibe for sure. Yeah, things are
从来不会在你的嘉宾或我的嘉宾身上遇到这种问题。我们总是准时开始。你知道，这不只是我。不是我。不是我。我总是很准时。不，是你的氛围。是的，绝对是氛围。是的，事情在
just disorganized in your life. You know, no, and it's they're not like his answer is just, no, no, they're not. But wait, I want to say about where we're all going tomorrow. We're all going together. Yeah, I heard we're going to we're going to
你的生活中就是乱七八糟的。你知道，不，而且它们不像他的回答那样，不，不，它们不是。但等等，我想说一下我们明天都要去哪里。我们都要一起去。是的，我听说我们要去
be in a place where you can be a part of the sneaky culture. You're sneaky culture. I was so shocked because it's I'm a day of life and I texted well. I was like, I think I already know the answer. But just, you know, we're all going. I can't
一个你可以参与“鬼鬼祟祟文化”的地方。你的“鬼鬼祟祟文化”。我当时太震惊了，因为那是我的日常生活，我发短信说，好吧。我想我已经知道答案了。但只是，你知道，我们都要去。我无法
imagine you want to go. And he's like, Oh my God, I'm so excited to go. I was like really awesome. So listen to what this is is Hollywood Bowl out here in La La Land is this big place where the outdoor or the or the orchestra is La La Land. Just a
想象你想去。他说，哦天哪，我太兴奋了。我说真的太棒了。所以听着，这是洛杉矶好莱坞露天剧场，这是一个很大的地方，户外或者管弦乐队就在这里。就在
couple of years ago, they played each summer. The LA Philharmonic plays the Hollywood Bowl and then the winter they go inside. But during the summer, they played Hollywood Bowl and then they run three movies each summer or three or four and
几年前，他们每年夏天都会演出。洛杉矶爱乐乐团在好莱坞露天剧场演出，冬天他们会去室内。但在夏天，他们在好莱坞露天剧场演出，然后他们每年夏天会放映三部电影，或者三到四部，
they drop a big screen down and it's usually some big, huge cinematic film that's got a big orchestral score and they drop the music out and the symphony plays the music while they still keep the music or the dialogue in the sound effects.
他们会降下一块大屏幕，通常是一些宏大的电影，有宏大的管弦乐配乐，他们会去掉原声，由交响乐团现场演奏音乐，同时保留电影里的对白和音效。
And I'm like, Oh my God. I mean, I'm sorry, listener. I will send each of you your minute, your minute hour. But what I'm trying to sometimes it should be the listener should know that sometimes when we're in a social setting and you know what
我当时就想，哦天哪。我是说，抱歉，听众朋友们。我会给你们每人一分钟，你们的一小时。但我试图表达的是，有时候听众应该知道，当我们处于社交场合时，你知道我的意思，
I mean, I'll look over Jason. I'll see him talking to somebody, especially somebody who's new to our circle. And I'll see him talking about what they do. And I'll be like, This person is really struggling, but they're also a big Ozark fan. So
我会看向Jason。我会看到他在和某人交谈，特别是那些刚加入我们圈子的人。我会看到他在谈论他们的工作。我会想，这个人真的很挣扎，但他们也是《黑钱胜地》的忠实粉丝。所以我
I'm excited. I mean, we fuck me. This guy gets to the fucking point. So I'm excited. But Jason, Jason, I should say this. Also, I'm glad that Jason's driving because I'm going up to the Jason. I'm driving with them. I'm their
很兴奋。我是说，去他的。这家伙直奔主题。所以我很兴奋。但是Jason，Jason，我应该说这个。我也很高兴Jason在开车，因为我要去……Jason。我和他们一起开车。我是他们的
kid. You're glad I'm driving. Why are you going out tomorrow night? You're just going to get all banged up. No, just so that you and I can because I don't want to deal with parking at the bowl. Like that was one of my big thoughts. Well, Sean was
孩子。你很高兴我在开车。你明天晚上为什么要出去？你只会把自己搞得遍体鳞伤。不，只是为了让你和我可以，因为我不想处理露天剧场的停车问题。那是我最大的顾虑之一。好吧，Sean
nice enough. Now, Listener, you know, there was parking with it was another step that I didn't think you had, but I'm excited to go. By the way, the other thing I forgot to tell Well, Jason was my massage in the Bahamas. I can't believe I
人很好。现在，听众朋友们，你们知道，停车是另一个我没想到的步骤，但我很兴奋去。顺便说一句，我忘了告诉你们另一件事，Jason是我的巴哈马按摩师。我不敢相信我
haven't told you about the massage in the Bahamas. To what? Who me or Will? Oh, sorry. Massage in the Bahamas. Okay, sorry. Okay. Yeah, you said that a little quick. Yeah, I'm sorry. I'm almost like you. I'm not going to
还没告诉你们关于巴哈马按摩的事。什么？谁？我还是Will？哦，抱歉。巴哈马按摩。好吧，抱歉。好吧。是的，你刚才说得太快了。是的，我很抱歉。我几乎和你一样。我不会
say. No, but I've never had this happen in my entire life Okay, yeah, no, so so we splurge were like, you know, hey, let's get hey, let's get misogynist So I had this woman who was very very strong a lot stronger than I am and she Wasn't doing anything crazy or questionable, but she until she she was you know, I was on my I flipped over on my back And she's doing my leg and just rubbing right up against my penis in my balls Well, let's let's let's be a little bit more specific here. She wasn't rubbing up against she the back of her hand was on him
说。不，但我这辈子从来没遇到过这种事。好吧，是的，不，所以我们挥霍了一把，我们想，嘿，让我们去按摩吧。所以我找了那个女人，她非常非常强壮，比我强壮得多，她没做什么疯狂或可疑的事，但直到她，你知道，我翻过身躺在背上，她在按摩我的腿，一直摩擦着我的阴茎和睾丸。好吧，让我们说得具体一点。她没有摩擦，她的手背碰到了他。
Yeah, gave me some some some brushbys, right? She she gave me brushbys, but literally like no She didn't give a shit about anything. She's just rubbing right next to it over and over again And it's growing a little bit. Hmm. And so I thought well, I don't want to give her the wrong idea But anyway, it's like it was almost like medical like she didn't care. I'm gay Yeah, I think she knew that and that's why she was giving you the drive-bys Yeah, I didn't get any of that and she had just worked on my wife So she knew that maybe the you know, she's she ought to mind it with her with with you She didn't she didn't have to worry about safe zone. Yeah, she thought there's no way this guy's gonna be
是的，给了我一些擦碰，对吧？她给了我一些擦碰，但真的就像，不，她根本不在乎任何事。她只是反复地在旁边摩擦。它有点变大了。嗯。所以我心想，好吧，我不想给她错误的暗示。但无论如何，这几乎就像是医疗行为，她根本不在乎。我是同性恋。是的，我想她知道这一点，这就是为什么她给你那些擦碰。是的，我一点也没感觉到。而且她刚给我妻子做完按摩，所以她知道，也许，你知道，她应该介意她和你在一起。她不需要担心安全区。是的，她认为这家伙不可能
offended or aroused or anything like that and then sure enough here comes your But if you're rubbing up against it wouldn't you be like maybe I should switch my hands around maybe she's dead Oh, maybe the back of her hands are done. How about you not get an erection? Okay? I know I couldn't I know I Started just Scotty know that that you were aroused by this. He was in them. He was right next to me. It was a couple thing with another woman doing Okay, okay, here's what here's here's I'm glad you brought this up because I want to bring this up as you can imagine I take issue. I feel like every week's just become me with my grievances, but we are thinking about a new title the couple The couples massage nobody wants that That's the worst. Well, no, I didn't that's just somebody hearing me because this is what I do
被冒犯或被唤起之类的，然后果然，你的……但如果你摩擦它，你不觉得你应该换个手吗？也许她……哦，也许她的手背是……你为什么不让自己勃起呢？好吧？我知道我不能，我知道我开始……Scotty知道你被这个唤起了。他在他们中间。他就在我旁边。这是和另一个女人一起的双人按摩。好吧，好吧，这就是，这就是，我很高兴你提到了这一点，因为我想提出来，你可以想象，我有意见。我觉得每周都变成了我的抱怨时间，但我们正在考虑一个新标题，“情侣按摩”，没人想要那个。那是做糟糕的。好吧，不，我没有，那只是有人听到我说话，因为这就是我做的。
But sometimes when I'm getting massage, I'll be like You know I catch myself. What was that? What was that? What sound was that? What do that mean? Like like falling asleep at like to the point where I'm like, oh, yeah I do that too. You know, and then you're slobbering and stuff. Who wants to do that next to somebody else? I think the couples massage is way overrated and then we offer couples massage. That's a deterrent It's a deterrent especially when you're laying next to me and I I'm I like to give a lot of feedback Because I feel bad that they don't know whether they're doing good or not and so I'm I do a lot of I can't imagine Yeah
但有时候当我按摩时，我会，你知道，我发现自己。那是什么？那是什么？那是什么声音？那意味着什么？就像睡着了，以至于我心想，哦，是的，我也那样。你知道，然后你流口水之类的。谁想在别人旁边那样做？我认为情侣按摩被严重高估了，然后我们提供情侣按摩。那是一种威慑。那是一种威慑，特别是当你躺在我旁边时，我喜欢提供很多反馈，因为我觉得如果他们不知道自己做得好不好，我会感到难过，所以我做了很多，我无法想象。是的。
Yeah, you do not you don't know you don't. Oh That's crazy a lot of stuff like that and my whoever I'm we're partnered with often times. It's my wife They get upset because I'm disturbing their Often times. Oh, that's got it. I do a lot of those. Oh, that's got this is a great transition I do a lot of I do it like real cutesy though. Oh, look what you're doing Look what you're look what you did good for you. Are you generous? Okay, here we go our guest today is a very close friend of mine and also good friends of all of ours actually She's an extremely gifted actress having won an Oscar fairly recently. What but I swear her voice is almost as busy as she is
是的，你确实，你不知道。哦，那太疯狂了，诸如此类的事情，无论我和谁搭档，通常是我妻子，他们会因为我打扰他们而感到不安。通常情况下。哦，那太好了。我做了很多那些。哦，那太好了，这是一个很好的过渡。我做了很多，我做得非常可爱。哦，看你在做什么。看你做了什么，为你感到高兴。你慷慨吗？好吧，我们开始吧，我们今天的嘉宾是我的一位非常亲密的朋友，实际上也是我们所有人的好朋友。她是一位非常有天赋的女演员，最近还获得了奥斯卡奖。什么？但我发誓她的声音和她本人一样忙碌。
It's everywhere. You hear it in duck tails finding Nemo the Adams family minions over the hedge so many documentaries medical commercials Her voice is fantastic. Also turns out. She was actually a very serious figure skater in real life I can't wait to ask about that the first few years of her career was spent with roles in tiny plays and she was ready to quit numerous times We've all been there until Aaron Sorkin I've got her in one of those tiny plays. I've got an audition for a tiny little show called the West Wing Please welcome the absolute best in the world ever. It's Allison in the world Listener. Oh my god. I was so nervous. I was gonna have to look at nothing listener Great like what do you call that kind of hat?
它无处不在。你在《唐老鸭俱乐部》、《海底总动员》、《亚当斯一家》、《小黄人》、《篱笆墙外》中都能听到，还有很多纪录片、医疗广告。她的声音太棒了。而且事实证明，她在现实生活中还是一位非常认真的花样滑冰运动员。我迫不及待想问问那个。她职业生涯的前几年是在小剧场里扮演角色，她多次准备放弃。我们都经历过，直到Aaron Sorkin。我在其中一个小剧场里看过她。我有一个试镜，是一个叫《白宫风云》的小节目。请欢迎世界上绝对最棒的人。是Allison。在世界上。听众朋友们。哦天哪。我太紧张了，我不得不看着虚无。听众朋友们，太棒了。你管那种帽子叫什么？
She's got a hat with a big feather on a pillbox hat with an ostrich feather Probably not a real ostrich feather. So everybody calm down It's not a real ostrich feather and a veil and there's a netting in front of your face. What's that called some net? It's it's a veil. Okay, it's a veil with dots on it. So it looks like I have big black acne But I don't know what like moles like moles like big moles beauty marks or I'm just gonna pull these down for a second to pull up my veil and put these back on I just wanted for effect you to see what I just came from to come to talk to you three handsome You just came from this place. All right. Go ahead. Take it. I can't hear what you're saying. So go ahead and say something nasty
她戴着一顶有大羽毛的药盒帽，上面有鸵鸟毛。可能不是真的鸵鸟毛。所以大家都冷静点。那不是真的鸵鸟毛，还有面纱，你脸前面有网。那叫什么？一些网？那是面纱。好吧，那是带圆点的面纱。所以看起来我长了很大的黑痤疮，但我不知道像痣一样，像痣一样，像大痣，美人痣，或者我只是要把这些拉下来一会儿，拉起我的面纱，再把这些戴上。我只是为了效果，想让你们看看我刚从哪里来，来和你们三个帅哥说话。你刚从那个地方来。好吧。继续。拿去吧。我听不见你在说什么。所以继续，说点刻薄的话。
Oh my god, look at you Look at you. Okay. Why do you look at this stunning? Okay. Well, where did you just come from? Awake? You well very good. Yeah Funeral scene and I'm doing that you had Kristen Wiig on on the program not too long ago. Yeah, that show we're doing for Apple It's an Apple series as yet Tie it's an untitled project and we're doing a funeral scene today and This is a 1968 Palm Beach
哦天哪，看看你。看看你。好吧。你为什么看起来这么惊艳？好吧。你刚从哪里来？守灵？你，嗯，非常好。是的。葬礼场景，我正在做那个。你不久前在节目里请了Kristen Wiig。是的，那个我们为Apple做的节目。那是一个Apple系列，目前还没有标题，这是一个未命名的项目，我们今天在拍葬礼场景，这是1968年的棕榈滩。
This is what a lady looks like at a funeral in 1960. Do you have to you? Does your character have to cry at this wake or were you happy about the death? Okay, so That's why I chose to wear these so you don't have to cry Dark sunglasses actors are lazy guys. We're all very very lazy people. It's hard I'm in a wool dress. It's outside. It's hot It's hard. Are you here? Are you in, California? I am in, California I'm in right now in a base camp with all the trailers in a parking lot. Oh, you're in the trailer. I'm in my trailer Yeah, look at that pop out. She's got a nice one there near that. It's is a very nice trailer
这就是一位女士在1960年的葬礼上的样子。你必须，你的角色必须在这个守灵仪式上哭吗？还是你对死亡感到高兴？好吧，所以这就是为什么我选择戴这些，这样你就不必哭了。深色太阳镜，演员们很懒，伙计们。我们都是非常非常懒的人。这很难。我穿着羊毛裙。外面很热。这很难。你在吗？你在加利福尼亚吗？我在加利福尼亚。我现在在一个基地营地，所有的拖车都在停车场里。哦，你在拖车里。我在我的拖车里。是的，看看那个弹出式空间。她那里有一个不错的。这是一个非常好的拖车。
It's the nicest trailer I've ever had I usually get I think when I did your movie Jason I was in a honey wagon. Wow and cut that out a second easy to cut that out This is a shot that's well worth taking and let's let's see a honey wagon is smaller than a regular Didn't you tell me that you were to you took a pee wash your feet and brush your teeth all at the same time, right? Isn't that how small it was? Hey, so now are you one of those actors? Have you ever had them blow the camphor into your eyes so that you can get some Tears going yeah, I you know what after a certain amount and you know I did a movie with Tony Collette called the way way back and she
这是我住过的最好的拖车。我通常得到，我想当我拍你的电影时，Jason，我是在一辆“蜂蜜车”（移动厕所）里。哇，把那段剪掉。一秒钟，很容易剪掉。这是一个值得拍摄的镜头，让我们看看，“蜂蜜车”比普通的要小。你不是告诉我你洗脚、刷牙都在同一个地方吗？对吧？那不是因为它很小吗？嘿，所以现在你是那种演员吗？你有没有让他们把樟脑吹进你的眼睛里，这样你就能流出眼泪了？是的，你知道，在一定程度之后，你知道，我拍了一部Tony Collette的电影叫《迷途知返》，她
She can bring the emotion like nobody's business and she had to do it over and over again at a certain point. She was like Bring it in. I can't do it anymore. And I was like, thank God I was so glad to see someone I respected so much do it because you should be able to Listen to this little trick here, Tracy is a tube filled with like menthol crystals in it And and the makeup artist will blow through one end and ruining show business for a lot of people right it irritates your eyes So much that you start to cry and then they go, okay quick roll it and you're Tell them how this sausage is made. Are you crazy? I once made the mistake of having them do that when I had my contacts in and a crystal got under with my contact
她能像没人能比的那样带来情感，她不得不一遍又一遍地做。在某个时刻，她说，带进来吧。我做不到了。我说，谢天谢地。我很高兴看到一个我如此尊重的人这样做，因为你应该能够。听听这个小技巧，Tracy是一个装满薄荷晶体的管子，化妆师会吹一端，毁掉很多人的演艺事业，对吧？它会刺激你的眼睛，让你开始哭，然后他们说，好吧，快拍。告诉他们这香肠是怎么做的。你疯了吗？我曾经犯过一个错误，让他们在我戴隐形眼镜时这样做，一个晶体掉进了我的隐形眼镜下面。
And I I mean literally the director was like, please you have you can't be that emotional Jason have you ever done it? Like have you ever gone on set and actually blown people? Yeah. Well, what do you mean? Oh wait, I'm just trying to get a sound bite. I'm trying to get a sound bite out of you. I'm trying to get a gotcha sound bite out of you Wait Alice. Okay. So wait, I did not know a couple things about you and I'm knowing you for 75 years I didn't know you really were a figure skater. I had no idea. I can't believe you didn't know that's like Who's how's you gonna know that? It's like it's never come up. It probably came up with a junket for itanya, right? Which we met Jason and I met at the junket for itanya. I mean not itanya
我，我是说真的，导演说，拜托，你不能那么情绪化。Jason，你做过吗？你有没有去片场真的吹过人？是的。好吧，你是什么意思？哦等等，我只是想得到一个声音片段。我想从你那里得到一个声音片段。我想从你那里得到一个“抓包”的声音片段。等等，Alice。好吧。所以等等，我不知道关于你的几件事，我认识你75年了。我不知道你真的是个花样滑冰运动员。我一点也不知道。我不敢相信你不知道。那是谁，谁会知道呢？这就像，它从来没被提过。它可能在《我，托尼亚》的发布会上提过，对吧？我和Jason是在《我，托尼亚》的发布会上认识的。我是说不是《我，托尼亚》。
Juno that's where I first met you and okay and fell in love with you and Sean I fell in love with just all throughout our emerging career is doing art during you know West Wing and Will and Grace right and will do you remember where we met? When we when we fell in love Uh, yes, vamp. Wait, wait, where did we meet? He doesn't remember. I'm very trying really Jesus Christ, I only met you once and I'll never forget it. Yeah. Oh show them a picture of your child You're not gonna remember it's okay, and it may not have been you I might have been wrong It might have been it might have been it might have been Patrick Wilson
《朱诺》，那是我第一次见到你，好吧，并且爱上了你。Sean，我爱上了，就在我们职业生涯刚起步的时候，在《白宫风云》和《威尔与格蕾丝》期间。Will，你记得我们在哪里认识的吗？当我们爱上的时候。呃，是的，Vamp。等等，等等，我们在哪里认识的？他不记得了。我真的很努力，天哪，我只见过你一次，我永远不会忘记。是的。哦，给他们看你孩子的照片。你不会记得的，没关系，可能不是你。我可能错了。可能是，可能是Patrick Wilson。
Oh, is that who you get? Do you ever remember you you've been to the Soho house in New York City, right? Sure. Yeah Well, it was a long time ago, and I met you there at the the bar at the Soho house I was there for my birthday, and you just happened to be there, and I met you so it's about 20 years Oh, 25 years ago. Was he was he probably 20 years 25, but like at least well actually 25 30 15 I don't know but I Interrupted because we're talking about skating and I did I know I was sick of talking about it No, I know I'm it's okay. I don't mind talking about because I really I did want to go to the Olympics
哦，那是你认错的人吗？你还记得吗？你去过纽约市的Soho House，对吧？当然。是的，那是很久以前的事了，我在Soho House的酒吧遇见了你。我当时在那里过生日，你刚好也在那里，我遇见了你，所以大约是20年前。哦，25年前。他是，他可能20年，25年，但至少，好吧，实际上25、30、15，我不知道，但我打断了，因为我们在谈论滑冰，我知道我厌倦了谈论它。不，我知道，我没关系。我不介意谈论它，因为我真的，我确实想去奥运会。
That was my my dream as a young girl. I was a really I was a great athlete in in school I played field hockey lacrosse ice hockey everything. I'm just I'm very athletic and of and I decided to oh I know why because my father was in commercial real estate in date in Ohio and Kentucky and Cincinnati and he owned a A you know building that housed of an ice rink So I got you know my little lifetime membership card and got free ice time and all of a sudden I just became infatuated with with skating. It was literally
那是作为小女孩的梦想。我在学校里是个很棒的运动员，我打曲棍球、长曲棍球、冰球，什么都打。我只是，我非常有运动天赋，而且我决定，哦，我知道为什么，因为我父亲在俄亥俄州、肯塔基州和辛辛那提从事商业房地产，他拥有一栋容纳溜冰场的建筑。所以我得到了我的小终身会员卡，得到了免费的冰上时间，突然间我就迷上了滑冰。这真的是
To it's the only time I've ever been when you're so excited I was so excited to put my skates on it could hardly get them on fast enough to get out on the Really and were you I bet you were great. I was very graceful, but I'm very very Tall so you're ice skating figure skating is an acrobatic sport. Yeah, you can't you know I can't get this six foot frame three times around Triple, you know, I should have been an ice dancer. That's what I should have been But something happened when you were a teenager that made you stop. I heard or something. Oh We don't talk about it. I mean when I almost died
这是我唯一一次当你如此兴奋的时候。我太兴奋了，穿上溜冰鞋，几乎无法足够快地穿上它们去到冰上。真的吗？我敢打赌你很棒。我很有优雅，但我非常非常高。所以你，花样滑冰是一项杂技运动。是的，你不能，你知道，我无法让这六英尺的身躯转三圈。三周跳，你知道，我应该成为一名冰舞运动员。那才是我应该做的。但当你十几岁时发生了一些事，让你停止了。我听说，或者什么。哦，我们不谈这个。我是说当我差点死的时候。
That is what you're great. You're the fuck. I'm sorry When we talked to her about some of her relationship failures I didn't know that and then we'll roll into politics and religion. Can I talk to you for a second? What is that? What about the outfits Allison tell us about your favorite? Answer this part first what I just say it's a story that anyone who knows me well knows the story So I'm surprised well two of you don't know this but I I went through a play glass window when I was 17 And I like lost three quarters of my blood. I almost died and it was pretty Brick and traumatic. How did you get through that? Why did you get go through a window? Did you not see it? I?
那是你很棒的地方。你是那个……去他的。我很抱歉。当我们和她谈论她的一些关系失败时，我不知道这一点，然后我们会谈到政治和宗教。我能和你谈一秒钟吗？那是什么？那些服装呢，Allison，告诉我们你最喜欢的？先回答这一部分，我刚才说的是一个任何了解我的人都知道的故事。所以我很惊讶你们两个不知道这一点，但我17岁时穿过了一扇玻璃窗，我几乎失去了四分之三的血液。我差点死了，那非常血腥和创伤。你是怎么熬过来的？你为什么穿过窗户？你没看见它吗？我？
Jason goes for fun. No, but I mean it's those horrible, you know At a party when someone goes walking right into one and usually they bounce off of it But you went through it. I did what I you know, the the awful part is there was a game going on with And and the girls the couples and the girls had balloons tied around their ankles and and the object was to pop Everybody's balloon so you were the only couple left with your balloon unpopped Yeah, and I was cheating because I had a strapless long gown on and I and I tried the balloon up around my knee So no one could get pop my balloon. I mean, I've been a cheater. I'm such a cheater Well, it takes a lot to admit that but so wait, how does it send you through a play glass window though?
Jason是为了好玩。不，我是说，那些可怕的，你知道，在派对上，当有人直接走进去时，通常他们会弹开，但你穿过去了。我做了，你知道，糟糕的部分是当时正在玩一个游戏，女孩们，情侣们，女孩们的脚踝上绑着气球，目标是弄破每个人的气球。所以你们是唯一一对气球没被弄破的情侣。是的，而且我作弊了，因为我穿了一件无肩带的长礼服，我把气球绑在膝盖周围，所以没人能弄破我的气球。我是说，我一直是个骗子。我真是个骗子。好吧，承认这一点需要很大的勇气，但等等，它是怎么让你穿过玻璃窗的呢？
Well, then one someone who was trying to pop my balloon kept Furiously trying to step on my balloon instead stepped on my dress and it ripped and fell off And I was there for the party with parents and kids and everybody was there And I just graduated from high school and and my dress was falling off I didn't have any bra and it was strapless dress and I'm a very small-chested woman And so I held the dress up and I ran to get inside and there was a porch with, you know Some doors open some clothes and I I hit it and then the glass fell on top of me on my leg And I the band was playing right next to me and I was I was like keep playing keep playing don't don't play
好吧，然后有人试图弄破我的气球，疯狂地试图踩我的气球，结果踩到了我的裙子，它撕裂并掉了下来。我和父母、孩子们一起参加派对，每个人都在那里。我刚从高中毕业，我的裙子掉了下来。我没有穿胸罩，那是无肩带的裙子，我是一个胸部很小的女人。所以我提着裙子跑进去，那里有一个门廊，你知道，有些门开着，有些关着，我撞上了它，然后玻璃掉在我身上，掉在我的腿上。乐队就在我旁边演奏，我当时想，继续演奏，继续演奏，别，别停。
I was so embarrassed and then I turned around and I I said, oh my god I saw blood all over my my finger and on my neck and everywhere and I said I'm supposed to now I'm supposed to scream and then I am gonna faint and then I'm gonna die And that's what as my actors had was like I'm these are the things I'm supposed to do right now I'm supposed to scream right and then You know it was like a Fellini movie or something being on the ground and seeing all these people come with cocktails and cigarettes Leaning over me looking to see what was going on with my blood and people it was crazy Oh my god, so you couldn't skate anymore. No, but my skating, but you know, it was it was it was good
我太尴尬了，然后我转过身，我说，哦天哪，我看到我的手指、脖子上到处都是血，我说，我现在应该，我现在应该尖叫，然后我要晕倒，然后我要死了。这就是作为演员，我想的是，这些是我现在应该做的事情，对吧？我应该尖叫，对吧？然后，你知道，这就像一部费里尼的电影，躺在地上，看着所有这些人拿着鸡尾酒和香烟，俯身看着我，想看看我的血是怎么回事，人们，这太疯狂了。哦天哪，所以你不能再滑冰了。不，但我的滑冰，但你知道，它，它，它很好。
I was not meant to be a figure skater At all, but I well, what about that injury wrecked your skating career? Well, I lost a artery my cut tendon in my lower right leg and my foot doesn't work so well anymore Oh, no, you couldn't you couldn't walk that off This is why we hired well our net it was real it was cheap and he he keeps it light and We will be right back. All right back to the show Wait one time. I was my sister was out here. Okay, it never goes well when such with one time my sister Okay, go ahead man
我根本不是注定要成为花样滑冰运动员的，但我，好吧，那次受伤毁了你的滑冰生涯吗？好吧，我失去了一条动脉，切断了右小腿的肌腱，我的脚不太好用了。哦，不，你不能，你不能走过去。这就是为什么我们雇佣了Will，我们的网是真的，它很便宜，他保持轻松，我们会马上回来。好吧，回到节目。等等，有一次我姐姐在这里。好吧，当这种情况发生时，从来没有好结果，有一次我姐姐，好吧，继续吧，伙计。
One time I was with my sister to stop light got it in In Century City and we're watching this girl She must have been 14 15 years old rollerblade what and she was it was on a long hill And she couldn't stop herself and you know when you want to see something and she ran she rollerbladed right into a movie poster And the glass complete at a bus stop and the glass completely shattered What was the movie do you remember? No, I don't remember it would be better if I had the movie ready, but I think it was like, you know chipmunks something about the Shattered glass and she ran over there to help her and she was like that you didn't my sister couldn't stop laughing
有一次我和我姐姐在世纪城的红绿灯处，我们看着这个女孩，她一定有14、15岁，在滑旱冰，什么？而且是在一个长坡上，她无法停下来，你知道当你想要看到什么东西时，她直接滑进了一个电影海报，公交车站的玻璃完全碎了。那是什么电影，你记得吗？不，我不记得了，如果我有电影准备好会更好，但我认为就像，你知道，花栗鼠之类的。关于破碎的玻璃，她跑过去帮她，她就像，你没有，我姐姐笑得停不下来。
I was like, oh my god, this boy. She turned to sit tell the band to keep playing No, she ended up being totally does that when they have this their first instinct is to tell the band might my sister My sister was laughing only because she knew she was totally fine because my sister was a cop and she was like Oh, the girl's gonna be totally fine. She was it looked way Tracy was a cop. Yeah, she's a cop. Yeah, we learned that. We learned that very late. Well, we were on stage for that We learned that when she hogtied Bateman in the back of a man You know, you know Allison I know I I don't want to I I did have a little figure skating in my time as well
我当时想，哦天哪，这个男孩。她转过身去告诉乐队继续演奏。不，她最终完全……当他们有这种第一直觉时，他们会告诉乐队，我姐姐，我姐姐笑只是因为她知道她完全没事，因为我姐姐是个警察，她就像，哦，那个女孩会完全没事的。她看起来很……Tracy是个警察。是的，她是警察。是的，我们学到了。我们学到了。我们学到了。我们学到了。我们是在舞台上学到的。我们是在她把Bateman绑在男人后面时学到的。你知道，你知道Allison，我，我，我不想，我确实在我的时代也有过一点花样滑冰。
Oh, here we come. I did I do well. I did I did it as part of the cinema. I did a I did a film I made a oh, yeah, figure skating picture called Blades of Glory. Yeah, he did all of his own skating and I didn't do all my own skating I didn't do all my own skating but of the four made of of me and Feral and Amy and John heater. I did the most of my own skating. Wait, did you know? Did you learn to skate just for that movie? Okay, you play hockey, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, at a very high level go ahead Golly, so it wasn't a weird that all that figure skating I mean
哦，我们来了。我做得很好。我做到了，我把它作为电影的一部分。我做了一部，哦，是的，花样滑冰电影叫《冰刀双人组》。是的，他做了他自己所有的滑冰动作，我没有做我所有的滑冰动作，我没有做我所有的滑冰动作，但在我们四个，我和Ferrell、Amy和Jon Heder中，我做了我大部分的滑冰动作。等等，你知道吗？你是为了那部电影才学滑冰的吗？好吧，你打曲棍球，对吧？是的，是的，是的，水平很高，继续吧。天哪，所以那所有的花样滑冰不奇怪吗？我是说
I can't be the first person to say this and then you win an Oscar for a movie about skating. I mean, it's just I know it's crazy Allison It's nutty. It's just nutty. I couldn't believe it And I actually got my skates back out and got on the ice and I thought that my character might They might put in a little scene where she skated and so you saw that, you know She wanted her daughter to succeed succeed where she had failed and then that part was so great Did you did you come up with the bird and the oxygen tank or was which one was because I love I'm obsessed with that role I tell you I I've never smoked so many cigarettes in my my life and and
我不可能是第一个说这话的人，然后你因为一部关于滑冰的电影赢得了奥斯卡奖。我是说，这太疯狂了，Allison。这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。我简直不敢相信。我实际上把我的溜冰鞋拿出来，上了冰，我想我的角色可能，他们可能会放一个小场景，她滑冰，所以你看到了，你知道，她想让她的女儿成功，在她失败的地方成功，那部分太棒了。你是，你是想出了鸟和氧气罐，还是哪一个，因为我爱，我痴迷于那个角色。我告诉你，我这辈子从来没抽过这么多烟，而且
Every scene I kept saying maybe this scene she doesn't smoke and Craig Gillespie the director was like no you're smoking You're smoking in every scene and then we get to that final scene with the with the bird and the bird handler was like You're not you can't smoke around the bird. You're not allowed to and Craig was like. Oh, yes, we are We're smoking around like there was a huge fight about it and I said To the prop guy said what do you do you have one of those those things those um, you know Things you stick in your nose and the canister the oxygen and yeah the action tank. Yeah, yeah, but I can't what's it called? Yeah, I got it on the top and he did exactly
每一场戏我都在说，也许这场戏她不抽烟，导演Craig Gillespie说，不，你在抽烟。你在每一场戏都在抽烟，然后我们到了最后一场戏，有鸟和驯鸟师，他说，你不能，你不能在鸟周围抽烟。你不被允许，Craig说，哦，是的，我们是。我们在周围抽烟，就像，关于它有一场巨大的争吵，我对道具师说，你有什么，你有那些，那些东西，那些，你知道，你插在鼻子里的东西，罐子和氧气，是的，氧气罐。是的，是的，但我不能，它叫什么？是的，我把它放在上面，他做了完全
Exactly Jason. That's exactly what he said and and that's how that came about that of course It made sense that my character would have emphysema after smoking for yeah, what about Craig Gillespie that guy? What a genius. He's amazing. He's pretty he's but I gotta say Jason You are been one of my favorite directors, too You are I there's no one more fun to watch on a set than you you you love I mean at least it seemed to me you love being in that position and just don't love it You just are able to handle anything that comes your way. You're such I had so much fun working with you on that
完全是Jason。那就是他说的，这就是它的由来，当然，我的角色在抽烟后患上肺气肿是有道理的，是的，Craig Gillespie那个人怎么样？真是个天才。他太棒了。他很，但我得说，Jason，你也是我最喜欢的导演之一。你，没有人比你更让人看着开心了，你，你爱，我是说至少在我看来，你喜欢处于那个位置，只是不爱它。你只是能够处理任何出现在你面前的事情。你真是，我和你一起工作太开心了。
Listen you guys why don't we all do I have proposed that we all do a sitcom I know you guys were talking about sitcoms recently on the yeah, let's do it great So we just make let's make news right now Okay, so what would the concept what would the concept be? How could we best utilize what the three of us do and you do and what would that concept be? Okay, well, let's let's let's um, I think you're already halfway there with the outfit on right now the funeral outfit Yeah, okay, so I'm a boxer right now. I'm like a young. I'm like the young. No, I think you know So I've got well. I've got you being a luggage porter at a hotel
听着，你们，为什么我们不都做，我提议我们都做一部情景喜剧。我知道你们最近在谈论情景喜剧，是的，让我们做吧，太棒了。所以我们只是，让我们现在制造新闻。好吧，那么概念是什么，概念会是什么？我们如何最好地利用我们三个所做的，你所做的，那个概念会是什么？好吧，让我们，让我们，嗯，我想你现在已经穿上那套衣服，已经完成了一半了，对吧，葬礼服装。是的，好吧，我现在是个拳击手。我像个年轻人。我像个年轻人。不，我想你知道，所以我，好吧，我让你在酒店当行李搬运工。
Allison owns I own the hotel. She owns a hotel and she's got three of us working there Will you're just you're doing a lot of luggage care. You're in charge of VIP relations Jason. Thank you I'm ballet. I'll do the ballet. She's Jason's like the mater. D. I agree Wait, listen, you're still in the luggage department. What are you on the ballet? Okay What's a valet do you mean the car parker or the guy that's taking care of our cars the concierge stuff parker But you fill in whenever wherever it's necessary. That's right You you you're on room service duty or you kind of jump around
Allison拥有，我拥有那家酒店。她拥有一家酒店，她让我们三个人在那里工作。Will，你只是，你正在做很多行李护理。你负责VIP关系。Jason，谢谢你，我是代客泊车。我会做代客泊车。她是，Jason就像领班。我同意。等等，听着，你还在行李部。你在代客泊车吗？好吧，代客泊车是什么意思，你是说停车的人还是照顾我们车的人，礼宾部之类的。停车，但你在任何必要的时候填补空缺。没错，你，你在客房服务岗位，或者你有点跳来跳去。
It's a multi-cam. We need to you gotta be at the front desk. We have to have the front desk So Shawn you need to be front desk and Jason your concierge. I'm sorry. I have to I do like Jason's concierge Let's put Shawn with an old-timey operator board. We've got a plug-in the little little phone We can't get cameras in there. I can't get Shimada in there Well, what did we decide you were I'm the bellboy because a real young seeming just very sort of boyish Yeah, the big back. I'm cutting people off. They want to agree with me. Go ahead. Who wanted to So Allison we get burrows to direct it, right? You think you can make his deal? Please I've never worked with him I want to work with him so badly. You've never worked with James Burroughs. No, I've never worked with him
这是一个多机位。我们需要，你必须在前台。我们必须有前台。所以Sean，你需要在前台，Jason，你是礼宾部。我很抱歉。我确实喜欢Jason当礼宾部。让我们把Sean放在一个老式的操作员板上。我们必须插上那个小小的电话。我们不能把摄像机放进去。我不能把Shimada放进去。好吧，我们决定你是谁？我是行李员，因为一个真正年轻的，看起来非常像男孩的样子。是的，大后方。我打断别人。他们想同意我。继续。谁想，所以Allison，我们让Burrows来导演，对吧？你认为你能达成他的交易吗？拜托，我从来没和他一起工作过，我太想和他一起工作了。你从来没和James Burrows一起工作过。不，我从来没和他一起工作过。
I've never worked with them. I'm very I'm sad about that didn't do any moms. No, no, no moms Who did the mom? Jamie widows the fabulous Oh my god, we love Jimmy widows. I love Jamie. Yeah, okay, so but wait I want to talk about your career because like you I've heard you talk about it before like the the agonizingly long kind of You know slow start in your career and what it took for you to get to where you are talk a little bit about that because Up until West Wing, I mean did Aaron Sorkin really see you in a play and just go oh, that's her for West Wing Is that how it worked? No, I think he's you know, I didn't he was I wasn't given that part I was up against a lot of very
我从来没和他们一起工作过。我对此感到很难过，没做过任何妈妈。不，不，不，妈妈。谁做了妈妈？Jamie Widows，太棒了。哦天哪，我们爱Jamie Widows。我爱Jamie。是的，好吧，所以但等等，我想谈谈你的职业生涯，因为像你一样，我以前听你谈过，就像那令人痛苦的漫长的，你知道，职业生涯的缓慢开始，以及你达到今天的位置所付出的代价，谈谈那个，因为在《白宫风云》之前，我是说Aaron Sorkin真的在戏里看到你，然后就说，哦，那是《白宫风云》的她，是那样运作的吗？不，我想他，你知道，我没有，我没有得到那个角色，我面对很多非常
talented ladies Yeah, but I think what sealed the deal for me is that Aaron saw me in primary colors Oh, yeah, and he's such a Mike Nichols fan as am I and I love Mike Nichols so much He was always so generous with me and He put me in that movie and that Prattfall I did was a big That just won me a lot of points. I love that now now Did you like are there roles you were up for and didn't get along the way or even now looking back
有才华的女士。是的，但我认为为我敲定交易的是Aaron在《原色》中看到了我。哦，是的，他是Mike Nichols的粉丝，我也是，我非常爱Mike Nichols。他对我总是那么慷慨，他让我演了那部电影，我做的那个摔倒是一个大，那为我赢得了很多分。我喜欢那个。现在，现在，你喜欢，有没有你争取过但没得到的角色，或者即使现在回想起来
You still wish you would have gotten them or does it all make sense now? I Was a lot there. I mean I was trying to think of a joke like you guys always think of something I was like no hold hold. We don't it's hard when Sean throws as much crap at the wall You know, oh, yeah, I know okay, so I I auditioned for the part of Roz in You know Frazier, are you your friend Perry Gilpin got that part? Oh, yeah
你仍然希望你得到它们，还是现在一切都有意义了？我，那里有很多。我是说，我试图想出一个笑话，像你们总是想出什么东西一样，我当时想，不，等等，等等。我们不，当Sean往墙上扔那么多垃圾时，这很难，你知道，哦，是的，我知道，好吧，所以我，我为Roz的角色试镜，你知道《弗雷泽》，你的朋友Perry Gilpin得到了那个角色？哦，是的。
You're both and then I auditioned for a third rock from the Sun and Kristen Johnson got that part So there were a lot of things I didn't get and then you want to work with burrows on both of those. Yeah Think about all the things think about all the things he doesn't like me think about yeah Well, there you go think about all the things you would not have been available for had you booked one or both of those Yes, well, I know and you know, I think it was meant to be that West Wing was the one that was meant for me And I mean it as my friend duly Hill says if it's not yours, it's can't be yours Mm-hmm. I gotta write that down doesn't sound bright He says it better than I just said it yours it can't be yours. I don't know it's some way of like it's just
你们两个，然后我为《歪星撞地球》试镜，Kristen Johnson得到了那个角色。所以有很多我没得到的东西，然后你想和Burrows一起工作，在这两个上。是的，想想所有那些他不喜欢的，想想，是的，好吧，给你，想想所有那些如果你预订了一个或两个，你就无法获得的东西。是的，好吧，我知道，而且你知道，我认为这是命中注定的，《白宫风云》是注定给我的。我是说，正如我的朋友Dule Hill所说，如果它不是你的，它就不可能是你的。嗯哼。我得把它写下来，听起来不太对。他说得比我刚才说的更好，你的，它不可能是你的。我不知道，这是一种像，它只是
Okay, everything's gonna be all right. Everything is happening the way it's supposed to happen This way you didn't have to hear a toss salad and scramble day all the time You know what I mean? You got you got a freebie on that What a bonus Toss salad and scramble Okay, so but wait so but growing up growing up your parents when did you go to the Royal Academy of drop of school? Whatever for theater the Royal Academy of Traumatic Arts I went there when I went to the neighborhood Playhouse in New York City
好吧，一切都会好起来的。一切都在按它应该发生的方式发生。这样你就不用一直听到“Toss Salad and Scrambled Eggs”了。你知道我的意思吗？你在这上面得到了一个免费赠品。什么奖励，Toss Salad and Scrambled。好吧，所以但等等，所以但成长，成长，你的父母，你什么时候去皇家戏剧艺术学院的？不管是什么，为了戏剧，皇家戏剧艺术学院，我去了那里，当我去了纽约市的Neighborhood Playhouse。
And they gave me a fellow that got a fellowship there to study at Radha and it was so funny to go all the way there and My teacher is American and every student in the class is American. So it was a great experience But it seemed kind of funny. I thought I was gonna be there with I did a summer program at Radha when I was when I was 18 Yeah Would did you have a lot of Americans in your class? There was a lot of dancer mime or what were you doing there? Do you guys want to see my dance belt
他们给了我一个奖学金，去Radha学习，去那里真是太有趣了，我的老师是美国人，班上的每个学生都是美国人。所以那是一次很棒的经历。但这看起来有点滑稽。我以为我会和，我在18岁时在Radha做了一个暑期项目。是的，你的班上有很多美国人吗？有很多舞蹈哑剧，或者你在那里做什么？你们想看我的舞蹈带吗？
Oh, I'm wearing no for theater. Yeah, did you do what Shakespeare monologue did you do well? Oh I think I did something Something from Lear, I guess Wait, wait wait from King Lear. Well, I think my sander or Demetrius or something from I'm trying to think sorry What's that Jason? I was just when you're done. I want to talk about you've done Shakespeare question mark Well, no, I mean I did it add to you had to do it at I did she was there for real I was just there for a summer doing a doing a program there No, my thing was a summer thing too. It wasn't a whole it was like six weeks
哦，我没穿，为了戏剧。是的，你做了什么莎士比亚独白？好吧，我想我做了一些，来自《李尔王》的东西，我想。等等，等等，等等，来自《李尔王》。好吧，我想我的桑德或德米特里厄斯，或者来自，我正在努力想，抱歉。那是什么，Jason？我只是，当你完成后，我想谈谈你做过莎士比亚，问号。好吧，不，我是说我做了，你必须在，我做了，她是在那里，真的，我只是在那里过了一个夏天，做了一个项目。不，我的事情也是暑期的事情。它不是整个，它就像六周。
And you know what here's the thing that really that really stuck out for me one was I had a teacher there and kept saying something something to the effect of like Hit hit the back row the back row and I was like, okay, got it got it So shout and then and then the other one was What was the guy's name? He was a this is like 1987 or eight and I did All the stage-finding stuff. I really it was that was fun Yeah, yeah, so which I still do a lot of that so wait but then didn't you do didn't you do Boarding school was that before the Royal Academy?
而且你知道吗，这里有一件事，真正让我印象深刻，一个是，我在那里有一位老师，一直说一些类似于，击中后排，后排，我当时想，好吧，明白了，明白了。所以大喊，然后，然后另一个是，那个人的名字是什么？这是像1987年或8年，我做了所有的舞台动作。我真的，那很有趣。是的，是的，所以我仍然做很多那种事。所以等等，但后来你没做，你没做寄宿学校吗？那是皇家学院之前吗？
No, no Allison. Thank you. Thank you. Well, thank you. Well Allison is this not my interview. No, sorry In fact, you can go up move your microphone just the whole arm of it just all the way to the right So Allison you're so you're in boarding school. Yes. Yeah, but is that before the Royal or after the Royal? That was way before that was that was high school dude. That was high school man I can't keep track. I don't know. I graduated high school and I mean, whatever 77. Where was where was boarding school? Where did you grow up? I grew up in Ohio, but I went to boarding school in Lakeville, Connecticut. Oh Was that fun? Wait, what school is that hotchkiss? Oh, you went to hotchkiss. I did That's where my eventually became like a school for a lot of like problem kids. It's it. I went to non-Hochkins
不，不，Allison。谢谢你。谢谢你。好吧，谢谢你。Will，Allison，这不是我的采访。不，抱歉。事实上，你可以去移动你的麦克风，只是它的整个手臂，一直向右。所以Allison，你在寄宿学校。是的。是的，但那是在皇家学院之前还是之后？那是在那之前很久，那是高中，伙计。那是高中，伙计。我无法追踪。我不知道。我高中毕业，我是说，不管是什么，77年。寄宿学校在哪里？你在哪里长大的？我在俄亥俄州长大，但我去了康涅狄格州莱克维尔的寄宿学校。哦，那很有趣吗？等等，那是哪所学校？Hotchkiss？哦，你去了Hotchkiss。我去了。那就是我最终成为像很多问题孩子学校的地方。它，我去了非Hotchkiss。
Sean save it for hypochondriac. Okay, no one understands that joke It was very high level but well above My my intelligence. No Allison. I knew a couple kids who'd gone to hotchkiss and like this is in the 80s and my Impression was that were they'd been they'd each been kicked out of other like one had been kicked out of Chote At the other what you know what I mean? It was kind of like that. Really? Yeah, but I Know Allison Well, I would imagine that you get sent so many tasty tasty things. How do you decide? Don't be so gross the way you described
Sean，留着给疑病症患者吧。好吧，没人听懂那个笑话，它太高深了，远超我的智商。不，艾莉森。我认识几个去过霍奇基斯高中的孩子，那是80年代的事，我的印象是他们每个人都是从别的学校被开除的，比如一个被乔特中学开除，另一个……你知道我的意思吗？就是那种感觉。真的吗？是的，但我认识艾莉森，我想你应该会收到很多美味的东西。你是怎么决定的？别说得那么恶心，你刚才描述的方式。
So tasty tasty, but how would you describe the characters that she plays? Fantastic scrumptious I'm just delightful. Just delightful characters. Just anything that doesn't we don't have to picture you licking your fingers, dude How would you decide you go? I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna really mash this metaphor out How do you decide what you want to eat? You know, God, which Like if I had chicken last night, I don't want something different I got you sure if I want, you know, like I just did okay, so I finished mom And then what I did was I went to do this movie Lou
太美味了，但你会怎么描述她扮演的角色呢？太棒了，太诱人了，我只是觉得很棒。非常棒的角色。任何不需要我们想象你舔手指的东西，伙计。你会怎么决定？你要去……我要把这个比喻发挥到极致。你是怎么决定你想吃什么的？你知道，天哪，比如如果我昨晚吃了鸡肉，我就不想再吃同样的了。我明白了，当然，如果我想，你知道，就像我刚做完……好吧，我拍完了《老妈》，然后我去做这部电影《卢》。
Yes Vancouver where I play it's a pretty Different kind of role for me and I I don't want to give away although the trailer does have some pretty I had to Let's just say I had to learn some hand-to-hand combat. Okay, so that's what I want to ask about because I just saw it It's fucking fantastic and language. You saw the movie. It was fantastic. Yes, and you and you It's a role that you've never I've never seen you do anything like this before. What does that mean? What's it? What does that mean the role? Because it's kind of like a tough like it's the female Liam Neeson. I like to think yeah for sure You're but guys, but guys, she's kicking ass like crazy
是的，在温哥华，我扮演的角色对我来说非常不同，我不想剧透，尽管预告片里确实有一些……我不得不说，我不得不学习一些近身格斗。好吧，这就是我想问的，因为我刚看了，它太他妈棒了，注意语言。你看了这部电影。它太棒了。是的，而且你……这是一个你以前从未尝试过的角色。那是什么意思？什么意思？那个角色是什么意思？因为它有点像一个硬汉，就像女版连姆·尼森。我喜欢这么想，是的，当然。但是伙计们，她打起架来简直疯狂。
Really, and I read somewhere that you train with like Charlize Theron and Halle Berry's guy Aaron, you know that like yeah, right and Daniel Bernhardt I don't want to give away the ending and I won't yeah, and and but the last scene one of the last scenes The butler did it. What? One of the last scenes you're on a beach and you're kicking the shit out of this guy and I'm going wait that has to be Allison it can't be the stunt person and he and he buries your face in the fucking sand and kicks the shit out and you kick the shit I'm like oh, yeah, what? Oh, yeah, I've got a lot of anger. I've seen a lot of anger under here. I'm so physically Violent as you must have hurt yourself just a little bit
真的，我读到过你和查理兹·塞隆和哈莉·贝瑞的教练亚伦一起训练，你知道的，是的，没错，还有丹尼尔·伯恩哈特。我不想剧透结局，我也不会，但是最后一个场景……管家干的。什么？最后一个场景你在海滩上，你把那个家伙打得落花流水，我在想，等等，那一定是艾莉森，不可能是替身，他把你的脸按进沙子里，然后你把他打得落花流水。我心想，哦，是的，什么？哦，是的，我积压了很多愤怒。我在你这里看到了很多愤怒。你身体上一定很暴力，你肯定伤到自己了吧。
I did I have some I definitely had some bruises This was something you know It's one of those things you guys have been talking about this when you see a script and you see it's nighttime a storm You know I was approaching and I'm like I'm out But but I did it this time and this was all this whole whole movie takes place during this massive storm that that hits the Lopez Islands, I mean those San Juan Islands I thought of that too when you were when I was watching I was like it raining in every scene Yeah, every single and and and wind machines. So in every scene. I'm like going
确实，我肯定受了一些淤青。这就像你们一直在讨论的那样，当你看到剧本，看到是夜晚，暴风雨即将来临，我就想，我退出。但我这次还是做了，整部电影都发生在这场袭击洛佩兹岛的巨大风暴中，我是说圣胡安群岛。我看的时候也想到了这一点，我心想，每一场戏都在下雨。是的，每一场，还有风力机。所以在每一场戏里，我都……
Well, you know screaming my line. So I ended up having to to loop a lot of them after the fact because I sounded so I To sound kind of cooler to have my voice registered down. Yeah, you know, hey, where are you going? You know to be but instead of going So the nightmare continued you're shooting nice So you got rain and then you had to ADR the whole thing and had to ADR a lot of it and we also shot it in during one Of the worst heat waves in Canada. Well, I don't know Yeah, that's something terrible. It was and nobody in Vancouver has air conditioning. No, it's like you don't need it
好吧，你知道，在尖叫我的台词。所以我最后不得不事后补录很多台词，因为我听起来……为了让我的声音听起来更酷，我把声音调低了。是的，你知道，嘿，你要去哪儿？你知道，但不是去……所以噩梦继续，你在拍摄，很好。所以你有雨，然后你不得不给整部电影做后期配音，不得不做很多后期配音，而且我们是在加拿大最严重的几场热浪之一期间拍摄的。好吧，我不知道，是的，那太糟糕了。温哥华没人有空调。不，就像你不需要它一样。
But it was pretty brutal. It was brutal. It was brutal on the wildlife in in Vancouver Yeah, but I worked with them a journey Smollett who was so game and great and so fun to Act with and I couldn't have done it with someone who would have been, you know, oh, it's so wet and muddy I can't you know, she was totally let's get in the mud together and so that was fun to do like a total It left for me and I was really amazing that and now I'm this lady and you know, it's it's fun to keep Shaking it up and playing so somebody wants to wants to grab you just make sure you check out what she did break before and off You the opposite exactly. Yeah, but really I was so impressed. It's such a good movie
但这相当残酷。这很残酷。这对温哥华的野生动物来说很残酷。是的，但我与朱尼·斯莫利特合作，她非常配合，非常棒，和她演戏很有趣，如果换成别人，可能会抱怨“哦，太湿了，太泥泞了，我不能……”你知道，她完全是“让我们一起跳进泥里吧”，所以这对我来说是一个完全的飞跃，这真的很棒。现在我是这位女士，你知道，不断改变风格去表演很有趣。所以如果有人想抓住你，一定要看看她之前做了什么，反之亦然。完全正确。是的，但真的，我印象非常深刻。这是一部非常好的电影。
And I was like, wow, look at you go and now a word from her sponsor and Now back to the show What were you doing with Mark Manchaka my other favorite person in the world down down in Australia? Maybe were you? No, I was in Thailand. Yes, Mark Manchaka is so I just love him so much my god for listener If you watch Ozark, he he played Russ Langmore the red-headed guy with the beard Oh, wow. That was a Julia Garner's Uncle yes, I think yeah, I should know that
我当时想，哇，看你表现得真好。现在是赞助商时间，现在回到节目。你在澳大利亚和马克·曼查卡——我世界上另一个最喜欢的人——在做什么？也许你在那儿？不，我在泰国。是的，马克·曼查卡，我太爱他了，天哪。对于听众来说，如果你看过《黑钱胜地》，他扮演了拉斯·朗莫尔，那个留着胡子的红发家伙。哦，哇。那是朱莉娅·加纳的叔叔。是的，我想是的，我应该知道这一点。
He's extraordinary. I went to do this movie called true love with John David Washington who is Just the most extraordinary. I'm a big fan of lovely talented generous kind man and and Manchaka was on it. We kind of were a duo two of us and you didn't go out at night at all with Mark Did you? Oh, no, he hates to have negronies. Yeah, hates going out after work. Yeah, we had Thailand We went to Thailand It was it was also very a very hot location and we traveled all around to Chiang Mai and But I I think the sex capital of the world. Oh, huh a little strange You keep saying I think you keep saying I think it is like and then you and then why are your fingers crossed?
他非常出色。我去拍了一部叫《真爱》的电影，和约翰·大卫·华盛顿一起，他简直太出色了。我是这位可爱、有才华、慷慨、善良的人的忠实粉丝，曼查卡也在里面。我们就像一个二人组。你晚上根本没和马克出去，对吧？哦，不，他讨厌喝内格罗尼酒。是的，讨厌下班后出去。是的，我们在泰国。我们去了泰国，那也是一个非常热的地方，我们到处旅行，去了清迈，但是……我想是世界性都。哦，哈，有点奇怪。你一直在说“我想”，你一直在说“我想”，然后为什么你的手指交叉着？
Yeah, why are you crossing? Jesus, it was that sounds great. I'd love to work in Thailand for a while It was it was the people there were so lovely and friendly, but it too was incredibly hot What I want to know too. I'm gonna go back to the early part of your career and say and ask you What are some of the like earliest things that you watched as a kid and we're like, man I want to do that. You know that you remember Carol and Carol Burnett is on this show. I'm doing on this Palm Beach No way. Oh, really? And I am now wordle friends with her I'm so excited we do wordle every day and that's great. How is you know, will will our nets got real strong wordle skills
是的，你为什么要交叉？天哪，听起来不错。我很乐意在泰国工作一段时间。那里的人非常可爱和友好，但那里也热得不可思议。我也想知道，我要回到你职业生涯的早期，问你，你小时候看过的最早的让你觉得“天哪，我想做那个”的东西是什么？你知道你记得卡罗尔，卡罗尔·伯内特就在这个节目里。我正在做这个棕榈滩节目。不会吧。哦，真的吗？我现在和她是Wordle游戏的朋友。我太兴奋了，我们每天都玩Wordle，这太棒了。你知道，卡罗尔·伯内特有很强的Wordle技巧。
What are your wordle skills like? I've tried to do Quortal and I can't do it. I can only do wordle and I'm not very good at it But it I haven't gotten I think I've gotten mostly in the the five out of six Will won't even talk to you now. Yeah, let me let me let me just say this because we've talked about it a few times I'm on a chain with a couple other people that Jason had to jump ship on because I get it tail between his legs We and we do octordal which is eight boards octordal, quartal, wordle And then we do and then we do the score of all three combined every we do it every day
你的Wordle技巧怎么样？我试过玩Quordle，但我做不到。我只能玩Wordle，而且我不太擅长。但我还没得到……我想我大部分时间是六次机会里猜对五次。威尔现在甚至不想和你说话了。是的，让我说一下，因为我们已经讨论过几次了。我和其他几个人在一个群里，杰森不得不中途退出，因为我……夹着尾巴逃跑了。我们玩Octordle，也就是八个棋盘，Octordle，Quordle，Wordle。然后我们把三个的总分加起来，我们每天都玩。
We've been doing it for almost eight months now every single morning and today. I had a 77 this is why I've quit go ahead start Good God, which is which is really tell us all how you could have got a 75 or That's why I quit guy just so now everyone's gonna hear it. I mean this fucking guy Here's my score. Now had I done X Y and Z I had a such a 50-50 on Quortal and I could have anyway doesn't matter I could have had how long does it take you to do in the morning? How much time do you spend on it before you start your day about ten minutes to do all three really? Yeah, yeah
我们已经坚持了快八个月了，每天早上。今天，我得了77分。这就是我退出的原因，继续吧，开始吧。天哪，这真的……告诉我们大家你是怎么得到75分的，或者……这就是我退出的原因，伙计，现在每个人都要听到了。我是说这个该死的家伙。这是我的分数。现在，如果我做了X、Y和Z，我在Quordle上有一个50-50的机会，我本可以……不管怎样，没关系。我本可以……你早上做这个要花多长时间？你在开始一天的工作前花多少时间？大约十分钟做完三个，真的吗？是的，是的。
Wow, thanks me forever to just do wordle. I do too. It takes me all day I look at it in the morning that I go away from it. What takes longer is reading Will's excuses wise score wasn't even lower That's what it really is. Scotty. Scotty knocked it out of the park the other day He his first guess was craze and then twice and the word was twice That's that well, that's just good guessing good guessing amazing. What's your first word will I can't tell you He can't tell you that come on. I can't do it. No, you should go with I did vowels for a while I think it's all about consonants. You do. Yeah, okay. I'm gonna try that tomorrow Twist turns out twist is a good one
哇，我做Wordle都要花很长时间。我也一样。我花了一整天。我早上看一眼，然后就走开了。更花时间的是读威尔关于为什么分数没能更低的借口。那才是真正的重点。斯科蒂，斯科蒂前几天表现得太棒了。他第一次猜的是“craze”，然后是“twice”，单词就是“twice”。那……那只是好运气，好运气，太神奇了。你的第一个Wordle单词是什么？我不能告诉你。他不能告诉你，得了吧。我做不到。不，你应该用……我有一段时间用元音，我想这全靠辅音。你用吗？是的，好吧。我明天试试那个。Twist，事实证明Twist是个好词。
It's not because no it's not Wait, so you watch so Carol and so you watch Carol Burnett growing up and that and that Inspired you to want to do that or like what made you really well I wanted to have my own Carol Burnett show when I was watching, you know, that was my dream I just thought that's what I want to do. I want to yeah, did you tell Carol Burnett what she means to you? Yeah, I had dinner with her the other night and I just I told her how much I loved her and I you know Is that the first time you met her? No, I've met her before but I've never worked with her like this and gone out to dinner with her and I had to
不是因为……不，不是。等等，所以你看着卡罗尔，你看着卡罗尔·伯内特长大，那激励了你想做那个，或者是什么让你真的……好吧，我小时候看的时候就想拥有自己的卡罗尔·伯内特秀，你知道，那是我的梦想。我只是觉得那就是我想做的。我想……你告诉过卡罗尔·伯内特她对你意味着什么吗？是的，前几天我和她一起吃了晚饭，我只是告诉她我有多爱她，我……你知道……那是你第一次见她吗？不，我以前见过她，但我从未像这样和她一起工作，和她一起出去吃晚饭，我不得不……
Do a scene with her in this where I guess I can't give it away. Um, don't don't give it away. Don't give it away No, I'm leave that to Sean. Yeah But I I had to do a scene with her where she doesn't say anything and I am the one who talks the whole time, so It was she literally says nothing. So it was you where'd you guys go for dinner? We went to the palm you did. I love them. Yeah, we went to the palm and we all had and Carol Oh my god, it's so great. She has a specific drink She likes to have and she has these cards printed up with a little a picture of her You know pulling her ear and her drink
在这部戏里和她演一场戏，我想我不能剧透。嗯，别剧透。别剧透。不，我把那个留给肖恩。是的，但我不得不和她演一场戏，她什么都不说，而我一直在说话，所以……她真的什么都没说。所以是你……你们去哪儿吃的晚饭？我们去了Palm餐厅。你们去了？我爱那家店。是的，我们去了Palm，我们都点了……卡罗尔，天哪，太棒了。她有一种她喜欢喝的特定饮料，她印了这些卡片，上面有一张她拉耳朵的照片，还有她的饮料……
The recipe for a drink and she gives it. I hope she's not mad that I'm telling you this Or she's not listening I guarantee she's not listening and she gives it to the waiter and so I got a copy of it That's pretty awesome. So whatever drinks she wants you just hands it to the waiter the same drink always Oh, oh, she's the carton. So she so wherever she goes. Yeah. Oh, that's fantastic. It's very specific It's like a cosmo, but what she likes it bubble gum bubble gum pink colored with a little bit of Quantro and it says all these exact amounts and everything it's kind of you know what you know It's great about that if you know what you like. Yeah, you just just ask for it. This is what I like I bet she's got her her cartoon up there on the wall, right her little
饮料的配方，她把它给……我希望她不会因为我告诉你这个而生气。或者她没在听，我保证她没在听。她把它给服务员，所以我拿到了一份复印件。那太棒了。所以无论她想要什么饮料，她只是把它递给服务员，总是同样的饮料。哦，哦，她是卡片。所以无论她去哪儿。是的。哦，那太棒了。非常具体。就像一杯大都会鸡尾酒，但她喜欢泡泡糖，泡泡糖粉红色的，加一点君度橙酒，上面写着所有这些精确的量等等，这有点……你知道，你知道关于那个很棒的是，如果你知道你喜欢什么。是的，你只是……只要点它就行了。这就是我喜欢的。我敢打赌她的卡通画就在墙上，对吧，她的小……
What do you have them anymore at the new at the new palm changed owners and it changed owners too Yeah, you know Steve Martin used to have cards that said if somebody came up to him He just would stop them and hand them a card and say this is proof you've met me Instead of a picture So you wouldn't have to take a picture or sign anything he just hands them a card Oh my god, I want to have this pretty good and he would leave the house with just a bunch of those cars I have I had my photo. I had one of those you know those
你现在还有吗？在新的……在新的Palm餐厅换了老板，也换了老板。是的，你知道史蒂夫·马丁过去常有卡片，上面写着如果有人走近他，他就会拦住他们，递给他们一张卡片，说这是你见过我的证明。而不是拍照。所以你不需要拍照或签名，他只是递给他们一张卡片。天哪，我想有这个，这太好了。他离开家时就带着一堆那种卡片。我有……我有我的照片。我有那种你知道的……
drawings on the wall at the at the old palm on Santa Monica and Mitch Hurwitz and I went we used to know the we used to go there so much. We knew the old Mater D And we said this guy said Rick and we said we what we want is because we'd seen one from like the 70s That was buried in the back. We were like we want a version of what we saw we want Our heads but on babies bodies that are wearing diapers and then they're sitting on a cloud And he said great, where do you want it? We said we want it right by the front door and he went right there Anyway, so when they close it when they when they just demolished the old one
墙上的画，在圣莫尼卡的旧Palm餐厅，米奇·赫维茨和我过去常去那里，我们太常去了。我们认识老领班，我们说……这个家伙叫里克，我们说我们想要的是……因为我们看过一张70年代的，埋在后面。我们当时想，我们想要我们看到的那个版本，我们想要我们的头在婴儿的身体上，穿着尿布，然后坐在云端。他说太棒了，你们想要它在哪儿？我们说我们想要它就在前门旁边，他就在那儿。不管怎样，所以当他们关闭它时，当他们刚刚拆除旧的那一个……
That's a while ago now that they demolished that They sent it to me the palm sent it to me and I've got it in my office a piece of wall Yeah, a piece of wall from the old palm with with that thing on it I wonder if the one and if the new york one's gone, too Because I was up there with I because I did nine five with them With dolly parton and we got ours up on the wall there at the palm But I I guess that's gone too now, but no one sent that to me That was such a good show and you were so good in it. I love that dolly was in the stage version of nine to five
那是很久以前的事了，他们拆除了那个。他们把它寄给了我，Palm餐厅把它寄给了我，我把它放在我的办公室里，一块墙。是的，一块来自旧Palm餐厅的墙，上面有那个东西。我想知道纽约的那一个是不是也没了。因为我和他们一起做了《朝九晚五》，和多莉·帕顿一起，我们的照片挂在Palm餐厅的墙上。但我猜那个现在也没了，但没人把它寄给我。那是一部非常好的剧，你在里面演得太好了。我喜欢多莉参与了《朝九晚五》的舞台版。
She well, she she was part of she was a collaborator on that version that I did with stephanie block and megan hilti Um back in 2010. I didn't know you were in nine to five. What a way to make a living Oh, I wish I would have seen that what that joke coming Did you guys read about that huge storm that's heading our way? No, well, no, they didn't say it's heading our way. They said that it's there's a potential for it Oh, oh, right. You're talking about the yeah, the big mother storm that's going to rain for months and months huge like There's also supposed to be an earthquake. That's the the big big one not just the big one the big big one When is that supposed to happen? That's uh, we're over too. We're over now
她……她参与了，她是那个版本的合作者，我和斯蒂芬妮·布洛克、梅根·希尔蒂一起演的。嗯，回到2010年。我不知道你演过《朝九晚五》。谋生之道啊。哦，我真希望我能看到那个，那个笑话要来了。你们读到关于那场正向我们袭来的巨大风暴的新闻了吗？不，嗯，不，他们没说正向我们袭来。他们说这是一种可能性。哦，哦，对。你在说那个……是的，那场巨大的母亲风暴，要下几个月的雨，巨大，就像……还有可能发生地震。那是“大地震”，不仅仅是“大地震”，是“超级大地震”。那预计什么时候发生？那是……我们已经超期了。我们已经超期了。
So you're talking about that article that was like in the LA times or the times in the new york times It was about massive massive rain coming our way like, you know, six inches of men Yeah, but but but hang on. Hang on. It's not you key. That's that's misleading. It's not heading our way They said it could that is something that is that is possible within the next like 20 years, right? Yes I read that you may just seem like it's kind of that we got to look out by thursday Don't don't bother washing your car I didn't mean to do that. I am a little bit of an alarmist. I guess it just Alison, where would you go if california was no longer inhabitable? Where would you live?
所以你在说那篇《洛杉矶时报》或《纽约时报》上的文章。那是关于巨大的、巨大的雨正向我们袭来，就像，你知道，六英寸的……是的，但是……但是，等等，等等。这不是……那是误导。它不是正向我们袭来。他们说它可能……那是可能在未来20年内发生的事情，对吧？是的。我读到过，你可能觉得好像我们周四就得小心了。别费心洗车了。我不是故意要那样做的。我猜我有点危言耸听。只是……艾莉森，如果加州不再适合居住，你会去哪儿？你会住在哪儿？
Um, I'll tell you what I'd get my niece my niece patra and her boyfriend. They both fly planes They have their pilot's licenses and they um, I wanted to mention my niece is Amelia air pet rescue She flies pets from rural areas to urban areas. You're saying petra flies pets Petra flies pets for Amelia air rescue, but she's they fly planes So I get in the plane with them and we take off and go we can cut that plug by the way It needs to be paid for Alison Amelia air rescue Amelia if I was on that plane, I'd be petrified. Oh my god Well, but where would you ask them to fly it to where would you like to live if it wasn't Los Angeles, New York?
嗯，我告诉你，我会带上我的侄女，我的侄女佩特拉和她的男朋友。他们都会开飞机，他们有飞行员执照，他们……我想提一下我的侄女是“阿米莉亚空中宠物救援”。她把宠物从农村地区运送到城市地区。你是说佩特拉运送宠物？佩特拉为阿米莉亚空中救援运送宠物，但她是……他们开飞机。所以我坐进他们的飞机，我们起飞，去……顺便说一句，我们可以剪掉那个广告。它需要付费。艾莉森，阿米莉亚空中救援，阿米莉亚，如果我在那架飞机上，我会吓坏的。天哪。好吧，但你会让他们飞到哪儿？如果不是洛杉矶，你想住在哪儿？纽约？
Maybe upstate New York. Um, and you know, I like Upstate New York very much. I love Burlington, Vermont area Lake Champlain Oh way upstate. Yeah way upstate like adirondacks type stuff Uh, yeah, but more on on the Vermont like grand isle um, um in the lake Champlain area I like Burlington, Vermont. I think that's gorgeous. Also the lake george area is fucking stunning I watch um, I watch this old house every sunday still and they had they just had saratoga springs on I thought that was real pretty That's beautiful. Um, like george is a little bit south of the adirondack. I mean, it's right there And then you go up north and you get to platzberg, which is at the top
也许是纽约州北部。嗯，你知道，我非常喜欢纽约州北部。我喜欢伯灵顿、佛蒙特地区，尚普兰湖。哦，非常靠北。是的，非常靠北，像阿迪朗达克山脉那种地方。嗯，是的，但在佛蒙特那边，像格兰德岛，嗯，嗯，在尚普兰湖地区。我喜欢伯灵顿，佛蒙特。我觉得那很美。还有乔治湖地区，太他妈迷人了。我仍然每个星期天都看《老房子》，他们刚播了萨拉托加泉，我觉得那真的很漂亮。那很美。嗯，乔治湖在阿迪朗达克山脉南边一点。我是说，就在那儿。然后你往北走，就到了普拉茨堡，在最顶端。
Yeah, and then you can take the ferry across from platzberg to Vermont. That's right. Oh, is that right? Oh, yeah, that's my country But um, now some kind of joked about like what you do on your days off and like what I know we gotta let you go But I I want to What do you what is it that you do like it's it's friday? You're you're not working. You're not working till middle of next week It's friday. What do you what are you like? All right? I'm gonna this is my plan for the next couple of days other than just getting on the couch and watching a tv show. Well I'll tell you I do um
是的，然后你可以从普拉茨堡坐渡轮穿过到佛蒙特。没错。哦，是吗？哦，是的，那是我的地盘。但是……现在有人开玩笑说你休息日做什么，像什么……我知道我们得让你走了，但我……我想……你休息的时候做什么？比如是周五，你没工作，你下周中期之前都没工作。是周五。你是什么样的？好吧，这是我接下来几天的计划，除了坐在沙发上看电视节目。嗯，我告诉你，我做……
I have uh watercolors. I like to do put a little um like What do you call it a still life together and do watercolors. I have knitting I like to do I also have a full gym. I have a trainer. I love to comes over and and and we work out together Um, I did just adopt a new puppy. So I have four dogs now and uh, that's Uh taking up most of my life is training this new puppy that I got so you're a home body You would love being at home. I love I'm kind of but I kind of feel like I I didn't think I was I thought I used to like to go out all the time, but now I just hang out at home. I'm really a very
我有水彩画。我喜欢做……把一点……你叫它什么，静物画放在一起，画水彩画。我有编织，我喜欢做。我还有一个完整的健身房。我有一个教练，我喜欢他过来，我们一起锻炼。嗯，我刚领养了一只新小狗。所以我现在有四只狗了，嗯，那……占据了我大部分的生活，训练这只我刚得到的新小狗。所以你是个宅家的人。你会喜欢待在家里。我喜欢，我有点……但我有点觉得我……我以前不觉得我是。我以为我过去喜欢一直出去，但现在我只是待在家里。我真的是一个非常……
I hang out at home with the dogs and I'm happy And that's what I love too, but I want to be invited to things, but no one ever invites me and I just Because you at our place Yeah, we guys invite will bring his cards and and show bring some chin chin. Yeah, I would love that I never get invited Let's do some tarot card readings We're gonna do some taroing. Yeah, and then uh, my mom does a lot of knitting. She does a lot of uh, I've got needle point things. I'm oh needle point forget me. Yeah. I know all about it
我和狗待在家里，我很开心。这也是我喜欢的，但我希望被邀请参加活动，但从来没人邀请我，我只是……因为你在我们这儿。是的，我们伙计们邀请威尔带上他的卡片，展示一下，带点中餐。是的，我很乐意那样。我从来没被邀请过。让我们做一些塔罗牌占卜吧。我们要玩塔罗牌。是的，然后……我妈妈做了很多编织。她做了很多……我有针线活的东西。我……哦，针线活，别提了。是的，我知道这一切。
My mom has bored us her whole family for years about it And we have to do yep Amazing feeling. I think that's a great thing. I will say she's listening my mom listens to it. She loves it But uh, and she's great. I have a feeling that needle point is something I'd actually fall in love with too I think so too like the the the monotony of the kind of and then it's it's a monotony of the story about it The knitting though is the thing that saved me through many family holidays when I was Things were stressful and you sit there with knitting and you could be in a room for a with who it's the most calming Thing to do and then those needles are handy in case one of those family members starts to really run their mouth
我妈妈多年来一直用这个让我们全家感到无聊。我们不得不做，是的。神奇的感觉。我觉得那是一件很棒的事情。我会说她在听，我妈妈在听这个。她很喜欢。但是……而且她很棒。我有一种感觉，针线活是我实际上也会爱上的东西。我也这么认为，就像那种单调的……然后是关于它的故事的单调。不过编织是我在许多家庭节日里拯救我的东西，当我……事情很有压力时，你坐在那里编织，你可以和一个……和谁在一起，这是最让人平静的事情。然后那些针在以防万一那些家庭成员开始真的胡说八道时很方便。
Exactly. Yeah Alice and janny we love you you have to go back to work In your trailer I really just let me tell you one fantasy I have when I listen to you because I listen to your show all the time Okay, it's a family show. Just keep the fantasy music But I have a fantasy of going on a road trip with The three of you a road trip to anywhere
完全正确。是的，艾莉森·珍妮，我们爱你，你得回去工作了，在你的拖车里。我真的……让我告诉你一个我听你们节目时的幻想，因为我一直听你们的节目。好吧，这是一个家庭节目。保持幻想音乐。但我有一个幻想，和你们三个人一起去公路旅行，去任何地方的公路旅行。
I would just be the bad. I would just laugh at everything you say You should come on the road test next year when we go back out on the road. I want to be if I could just I'll do craft service or something or we're gonna get your we're gonna get your knees We're gonna get petra and her boyfriend to fly the plane for us. Petra can fly us anywhere we want to go We'll fill the plane with petrol And oh my god, you're so you guys you're so quick Everybody's jumping in on the fun. Well, it's fun. We're having fun. We're having fun. I'm petrified You know that was enough. She's in
我只会是那个坏蛋。我只会对你们说的每一件事大笑。明年我们再上路的时候，你应该来参加公路测试。我想成为……如果我能……我会做后勤服务或者什么的，或者我们要让你的侄女……我们要让佩特拉和她的男朋友开飞机带我们。佩特拉可以带我们去任何我们想去的地方。我们要把飞机装满汽油。哦，天哪，你们太……你们伙计们，你们太快了。每个人都加入到乐趣中来了。好吧，这很有趣。我们玩得很开心。我们玩得很开心。我吓坏了。你知道那已经够了。她加入了。
Oh, everybody's in. Um, all right. Love you, honey. We took up too much of your time. We love you crazy I have to go back to my funeral now. I'm so happy and now I'm gonna I gotta go cry But tell wig are you gonna see wig go tell wig you were better than she was her birthday today Not that what's your birthday? Tell her we say I had a birthday. Guess what? I got a birthday present for you. The guy say it was the best. I was better than you No, just say that you were the best the best episode But play it off just and she and say how was it just go? I don't want to say anything and then say let me finish Of today. There you go. And she'll go. Oh you
哦，每个人都加入了。嗯，好吧，爱你，亲爱的。我们占用了你太多时间。我们爱你，疯狂。我现在得回去参加我的葬礼了。我太开心了，现在我要……我得去哭。但告诉威格，你要去见威格，告诉威格你比她更好，她今天生日。不是那个，什么生日？告诉她我们说……我过了一个生日。猜猜怎么着？我有一个生日礼物给你。伙计们说这是最好的。我比你更好。不，就说你是最好的，最好的一集。但把它演出来，就……说它怎么样，就说：我不想说什么，然后说：让我说完。今天。就这样。她会说：哦，你……
Oh, we do. No, I would do it like do it for real. Just go. How was it just go? Yeah, it was I don't know and just be like so you drop, you know really really lure her in Okay, what are you just going? I feel kind of back. They said it They said it was the best And then just that's the hammer, you know I'm totally doing that. I'm totally doing it. I'm gonna nail it too. It's gonna I'm gonna reel her in and Of course you are because you're an absolute killer. You're a killer, especially in the hat. God, you're a killer. We love you I love you guys. I will say happy birthday. We love you. You're a mega talent. It's so great to see you guys. Love you, sweetie
哦，我们做。不，我会像……真的那样做。就说：它怎么样？就说：是的，它是……我不知道，然后就像：所以你掉进去了，你知道，真的真的引诱她进来。好吧，你只是在说？我感觉有点背。他们说它……他们说它是最好的。然后只是……那是重锤，你知道。我完全会那样做。我完全会做到的。我也会搞定的。它会……我会把她引进来，当然你会，因为你是一个绝对的杀手。你是一个杀手，特别是在戴帽子的时候。天哪，你是个杀手。我们爱你。我也爱你们。我会说生日快乐。我们爱你。你是一个超级天才。很高兴见到你们。爱你，亲爱的。
All right, we love you. Bye Bye. Love you guys. I'm just gonna click out. I'm gonna leave. Yes, or slam it or slam the laptop. I'm going to leave leave Have either one of you fellas worked with that incredible lady? No. Yes many times. Yeah, you have Yeah, she's been a friend for a long time like she'll if you want her to do You know, she's always there for you if you have like this great part and you just You see her in it and you're just like I wrote this for you or I have this for you in mind She's like, yeah, definitely, you know, she's always kind of there and she's great. She's a good good friend
好吧，我们爱你。再见。再见。爱你们。我只是要点掉。我要离开。是的，或者猛地关上。或者猛地合上笔记本电脑。我要离开，离开。你们两个伙计和那位不可思议的女士合作过吗？不。是的，很多次。是的，你有。是的，她是一个很长时间的朋友，就像她会……如果你想让她做……你知道，如果你有这个很棒的角色，你只是……你在里面看到她，你只是觉得：我为你写的，或者我心里有这个角色给你。她会说：是的，绝对，你知道，她总是那种在那儿的人，她很棒。她是一个很好的朋友。
She's again one of those people who is No matter what the thing is, that's right. She's always great. Yeah, never sucks There's only ever actors. Yeah. Yeah that that they always hit it. No matter what the John Goodman syndrome Yeah, John Goodman's that way. No matter what John Goodman's in. He's always amazing. And then there are a few people Now she's in there. We'll just we'll like we'll let's create a little file Um, yeah, Allison was great though. Um, and and I love that we all kind of know where I know will you don't know her as well But I don't really but I feel like I know her. Um, she's just the best. There's a reason why she works all the time is because She's the coolest. She's just really down to earth and cool
她又是那种无论是什么事情，都是……没错。她总是很棒。是的，从不糟糕。只有演员。是的。是的，他们总是能演好。无论是什么，约翰·古德曼综合症。是的，约翰·古德曼就是那样。无论约翰·古德曼演什么，他总是很棒。然后有几个人……现在她在里面了。我们会……我们会……让我们创建一个小文件。嗯，是的，艾莉森很棒。嗯，而且我喜欢我们都知道……我知道威尔，你不太了解她，但我真的不了解，但我感觉我了解她。嗯，她就是最好的。她一直工作是有原因的，因为她是最好的。她真的很脚踏实地，很酷。
Yeah, what do you guys got the rest of the day? I'm gonna go eat something. I had two bucks. Wow. Hang on a second. I can't stop the presses Really? Can we guess what it is? Oh, yeah, but did you hear me? I'm listening. It's 542. Yeah, you're in LA Can you go for us? It's going to be today is going to be uh, he's gonna make homemade pizzas on uh, french bread loaf He's just gonna take some pasta sauce and pour it on top And he's gonna grate the cheese himself to make it seem like he's really doing something
是的，你们今天剩下的时间打算做什么？我要去吃点东西。我有两块钱。哇。等等。我不能停止印刷机。真的吗？我们可以猜猜是什么吗？哦，是的，但你听到我说的了吗？我在听。现在是5:42。是的，你在洛杉矶。你能为我们去吗？今天会是……他要在法式面包上做自制披萨。他只是要拿些意大利面酱倒在上面。他要自己磨奶酪，让自己看起来好像真的在做什么。
And he's gonna put in a toaster oven like I'm really creating something Uh, and while he's waiting for it, he's gonna have four bites of ice cream. Oh my god It's shot. Is that is that close to what you're having? It's kind of don't say it. Don't say yet. Don't say yet. Okay um You are See now as you're saying it's kind of close Uh, you have leftover pasta from a restaurant you went to And you're gonna reheat it
然后他要把它放进烤箱，就像我真的在创造什么一样。嗯，当他等它的时候，他要吃四口冰淇淋。天哪。是……那和你吃的东西接近吗？它有点……别说。别说。别说。好吧，嗯……你是……看，现在你说它有点接近。嗯，你有从你去过的餐厅剩下的意大利面。你要重新加热它。
Or you you're gonna go pick up from a pasta restaurant. You're going to pick up Italian food. That's exactly right From uh, is it mariano's or whatever marino's marino's. Yeah, best Italian restaurant. Yeah Is there gonna be garlic bread involved with this? Absolutely. But last night I had did I tell you I I'm not making this up I had two boxes of mac and cheese Oh god Anyway craft mac and cheese craft macaroni cheese. Was it extra cheese? No, just the regular just the regular I'm sorry about eating. You know, we had that debate a while ago. We had sorry You can go ahead. You know in canada we call craft. They call it's called craft dinner. I'm not kidding
或者你……你要去意大利面餐厅取餐。你要去取意大利食物。完全正确。从……是马里亚诺还是什么的？马里诺。马里诺。是的，最好的意大利餐厅。是的。这会有大蒜面包吗？绝对会有。但昨晚我吃了……我告诉你了吗？我没编造。我吃了两盒通心粉和奶酪。哦，天哪。不管怎样，卡夫通心粉和奶酪。卡夫通心粉和奶酪。是特浓奶酪吗？不，只是普通的，只是普通的。我很抱歉关于吃的问题。你知道，我们前段时间有那个辩论。我们很抱歉。你可以继续。你知道在加拿大我们叫卡夫。他们叫……它叫卡夫晚餐。我没开玩笑。
Yeah, forever. It's called in the craft macaroni cheese is branded as craft dinner. So Right and the thing I don't understand is growing up. They're like feeds a family of four and I'm like it feeds I need two boxes of it feeds a family of four super models. Hey, do you Do you Remember we had the debate about the about the checks mix and the bugles Yes And um, Jason, do you remember that? No, I don't think so
是的，永远。它叫……卡夫通心粉和奶酪被品牌化为卡夫晚餐。所以……对，我不明白的是，从小到大，他们说“供四口之家食用”，我心想……它供……我需要两盒，它供四口超级名模之家食用。嘿，你……你记得我们关于切克斯混合零食和号角脆片的辩论吗？是的。嗯，杰森，你记得吗？不，我不这么认为。
Yeah, that's not surprising. I look at that vacant look on his face. It's unreal. That must have been a year or so It's just like we get one of those motel signs. It just says vacant So we had a debate about bugles and and and it turns out checks mix and bugles are made in the same factory We had a thing and then they sent us all the bugles. I will say when the bugles are incredible I I can't get enough of those bugles. I love the regular and the ranch flavored ones. They're all good You're about to get a box. So I just want to say to all the people of america and canada, I guess And uh, wherever you bugles are available. Go grab them because they are fantastic Okay, what if the what if bugles were spelled instead of b u g they were spelled b i g here it comes
是的，那并不奇怪。我看着他脸上那种茫然的表情。那是不真实的。那一定是一年前左右的事了。就像我们得到那些汽车旅馆的招牌之一，上面只写着“空房”。所以我们关于号角脆片进行了一场辩论，结果发现切克斯混合零食和号角脆片是在同一个工厂生产的。我们有一件事，然后他们把所有的号角脆片都寄给了我们。我会说当号角脆片不可思议时，我无法满足于那些号角脆片。我喜欢普通的和牧场风味的。它们都很好。你快要得到一盒了。所以我只想对美国和加拿大的所有人说，我想……无论哪里有号角脆片。去买吧，因为它们太棒了。好吧，如果……如果号角脆片拼写不是B-U-G，而是B-I-G，会怎么样？它来了。
You mean Oh my god Oh, it's so lazy, but we'll allow it smart Smartless is 100 organic and artisanly handcrafted by rob armjurf Bennett barbaco and michael grand terry SmartLas There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你是说……哦，天哪。哦，太懒了，但我们会允许的。Smartless是由罗伯·阿姆杰夫、本内特、巴巴科和迈克尔·格兰德·特里100%有机和手工制作的。SmartLess。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。